um the St was was supposed to be a
workshop then it was supposed to be a
talk then it was supposed to be a
workshop and it ended up being a talk so
at the end I'm going to try to run uh
over a quick demo on synthetic data and
I'm going to give you a few tools and a
few uh tips and tricks to get started
with it but the whole of the talk is
going to be um about what is synthetic
data uh how can we think of it and then
I have a few fun examples that hopefully
at least make you laugh U if you want to
access the slides uh there's the QR code
there and then you can have them um and
yeah so let's get
started um so bit about the agenda I'm
going to let me introduce myself as well
because I haven't uh told you anything
about me uh we're going to talk about
fake data we're going to talk about
synthetic data we're going to talk about
machine learning generated data we're
going to go through the demo and then
I'm going to have a final thought for
you um so if you thought that all those
three were the same you're probably
correct if you thought that all three of
those were different you're also correct
um so
so let me introduce myself my name is
Ramon um I am originally from the
Dominican Republic I came to the US
study here lived here 10 years moved to
Australia um here in the US I worked as
a researcher ver in Kansas City at a
company that does Consumer Behavior then
at a small think tank in Washington DC
then I moved to Australia I became an
educator and I was also doing research
at a university in with a university in
Singapore at the intersection of machine
learning and management Sciences I've
done a lot of um I've worked on a I've
been fortunate enough to work on a lot
of amazing projects from um NLP to
different use cases and um T using
tabular data um to also different use
cases using deep learning and now I work
as a developer advoc at seld at seld we
are a machine learning infrastructure
company focusing on the last end of the
machine learning life cycle when you
think about you train your model you
have evaluated it you already have a
some artifact that you want to deploy
and you ready to put it somewhere uh we
are that company we build those tools
that help you go and Achieve The Last
Mile over not only do we let you serve
it but we also help you uh evaluate um
the outputs that your Motel uh that your
Motel gives you and also to monitor the
inputs that go into your uh into your
work so that's a little bit about me
what I'm doing right now I'm based in
London
um um I missed the us a little bit uh
Australia Australia was quite fun too I
moved there right before uh what they
call there the bush fires here we call
it wild wildfires and so I had a very
warm welcome to Australia and but anyway
so that's a little bit about me let's
talk about um the the meat of the
session the the main thing of the
session so U all the data synthetic data
what do we mean by that when we say
synthetic data well if you think about
real data or and you might you might
think of data that we
can not technically see cu the actual
defition defition of data or not the
actual definition but the way in which
we think of data is things that are
intangible when you think of these
numbers you and you write them in a
piece of paper yeah you can touch the
piece of paper but you cannot touch that
number or that that piece of information
that represents something in the real
world so um real data let's put it into
one bubble and then what could exist
let's put it into another bubble and
that's what we're going to call U it
doesn't need to be real but it could be
real data so what are we talking about
so when we see something uh when we
don't see something or the things that
we can imagine that are real and the
things that are not let's think about
the space of possibilities and that's
what we're going to live today and we're
going to talk about what is synthetic
data into that domain that could be real
but it doesn't have to be and we can see
it or we could use it so first there is
synthetic data something that could come
from uh the real world and then next is
machine learning uh generated data it
could come from the real world but it
could be very well something that has
never existed before I'm sure some of
you that have already been seeing and
hearing and probably even been sick of
the hype of U llms and all this stuff um
in all the social media um You probably
heard of the word hallucination and you
probably heard other words uh or it's
making up uh so that's the domain
where we were like okay where did that
come from um maybe it came from
something real maybe it didn't um
because right now there's a um uh there
have been recent uh papers and studies
on uh how machine learning models can
degrade if they are trained on synthetic
data that was generated by the same
machine learning methods um so then the
last one is fake data um I put it into a
small bubble here but honestly it could
be it could be quite wide it could be it
could even be wider than the other two
that that you see over there so take
that as a very um why point of view my
point of view um so those are kind of
like that's kind of the spectrum that I
want you to imagine uh for the for the
rest of the talk and then so so what is
fake data can anybody here tell me what
do you think fake data
is anybody y uh data that doesn't
necessarily come from like a a source
like it's not generated from actual
observation or other sorts of data
collection methods right that's correct
it's random sorry fake numbers fake
numbers exactly it's it's fake numbers
it's something that doesn't exist could
it look real it could look real it could
look real right so now we have the right
definition of fake data so um it is um
you know stuff that is fake stuff that
is completely bogus it doesn't need to
exist it could look real um but it
doesn't it it could sound like a good
story but it might very well be a made
up story um but seriously it's it's fake
it's
um completely random nonsense stuff
um so here is a good example uh this
person is completely fake and made up
made up my GL I'm sure a lot of you have
seen this movie and you probably know uh
what what we're talking about another
example will be the famous lurm imun
ipsum whatever that you put as a
placeholder inside of uh inside websites
where you're building something so when
your front end team um has an idea of
the business logic of what your
application is going to look like what
it should be doing but they don't
necessarily have the content or the
copyright they want to put a placeholder
to see how things look then they turn to
fake data or uh synthetic or not
synthetic data but fake data data that
things that you can just put somewhere
so we're on the right track now so what
about um how do we make it uh how do we
make synthetic data well there's
different ways right now in Python and
um so two I think my favorite library
that and the one that we're going to
walk through uh today is called my
misses um I I also thought it was mimses
but it's not it's my Miss and it comes
from a Greek god I believe um it's a
really nice tool that allows you to
access randomly generated data from
different locals if you are trying to
put data from into a website that you're
building and it's fake just as a
placeholder and you are from a specific
part of the world that speaks a specific
language maybe you don't want to use
English maybe you want to use another
one and that's what it means when I
refer that's what I mean when I refer to
the world local um then there's faker
one of the most famous ones and one of
the most widely used ones you can
generate synthe um fake data with nonp
you can generate it with py you learn
there's another one Pi DB gen um that
I've seen it hasn't been active for
about 3 years so I don't know I think it
still works uh but I haven't really
tried it it seems like um it picked up a
lot of momentum because it allows you to
create pandas data frames uh and there's
another one called synth um and it's a
command line uh tool built on R is
actually quite nice but the way in the
way in which you define your the
synthetic data that you want in the
distribution that is going to come from
um or how you want your random numbers
to be generated uh comes from a Json
file so it's quite nice uh then why is
this important well um you can test
systems without exposing real data if
you're going to put a placeholder there
and you're going to break a whole system
or rack up a really big bill um then you
might as well put some synthetic data
there as opposed to data that comes from
your users if you are Tes and say V2 or
your website or um even if you're
testing a machine learning model create
some something just see if the requests
are coming in are going in uh correctly
if the request if the output is coming
in uh fine back to
you um so then you can speed up
development because you don't have to go
and access things that maybe don't have
uh the right credentials for uh you can
uh do training and education there's a
I'm sure a lot of you have probably come
across tutorials that use fake data of
some sort or some of you uh when you
have gone to the psychic learn docks the
first thing that you notice at the very
beginning is make blows or make uh
regression uh data and so on so that
helps for educational purposes um
scenario simulations uh no labeling
needed so you don't have to worry about
oh am I going to have the right label
over here or not because you are doing
something that is going to take you
faster to where you want to go um it's
not the end goal so that's uh fake data
so what about synthetic data um can
anybody tell me what do you think
synthetic data is now that we just
describe fake data
is it generated from a
basine that's very good it is generated
from a baseline it is generated from
somewhere it didn't just come from th
there it looks like real it could be
real so um right now for example if I
was in the sample um in some database
that where that it was taken as the
Baseline to create some synthetic data
then in the new database you could put
Ramon and then you could put Smith or
something like that so Latino and white
doesn't really go uh very well but it
could you know so the name but it could
be real but it doesn't necessarily have
to be real but let's make that more
concrete um so what is it is a mirror
it's kind of like you can think of it in
to give you an analogy you can think
about it as a mirroring the uh the real
data um so but let's define it so
synthetic data refers to artificially
generated data that mimics the
statistical properties and patterns of
real world data without containing
actual observations um so that's another
way to to Define it so it mimics uh the
real world data because it gets drawn
from the distribution that generated
that when we think of data when we think
of things that we use to do statistical
analysis to do data analysis on um we
usually assume that there was a
distribution at some point in time in
some shape or form that created that
data the fact that you are here today
and say for example at the end of today
you fill out a survey there's a there's
some sort of distribution that you
randomly ended up here today and you
ended up till now that so something
created that data some sort of
distribution that we don't know and we
want to approximate it in some way so
how do we make it uh well you first
Define the problem that you that you
have say for example um you work at a
Healthcare Company you want to create
some uh models but you're not the most
the the best expert in machine learning
say you don't know if at some point in
time your model might leak information
about the people the the data the people
inside the data that it was used to be
trained with so Define the problem the
first thing that you want to uh you want
to do you want to create a new drug or
do something you're going to have to use
data that has personally identifiable
information the second one understand
the data that you have like what can I
use what should I not use do I do I need
to use it do I need to have it there do
I need to create synthetic data from
this particular sample if the answer is
no don't add it um choose a s model
there's plenty of models to choose from
um and this is something that blew my
mind when I first started looking at um
synthetic data generation techniques U
there's a lot of models to choose from
and you can there's if you don't have a
baseline U you can go with
like uh there's models that are easier
to get started than others so pick a
model uh make sure you educate yourself
in what the outcome will be from one to
the other uh train and
evaluate generate the synthetic data
validate the new data refine and iterate
and iterate and improve um and then
document and and report it so those are
things that you probably come across if
you have done a full data science
project for example or a full machine
learning
project okay so what tools can we use um
so there's quite a few but um something
that I want to point out in this one is
that about um two or three of this are
actually open source but not really open
source they're they're uh business
source licenses so synthetic data bolt
is probably one of the nicest ones right
now to generate synthetic data but um
it's not fully open sourc but I think if
I understood corre correctly the LW
jargon in the license um and that was
and and that wasn't easy it
was they don't want you to use their
tool to generate synthetic data and and
sell it as a product you can use it for
things that are going to improve your
product but you cannot use it uh for
something that will compete with them
using their own product fair enough um
there's 25 I haven't used it but it seem
quite nice um SD metric is for metrics
to calculate different things from your
destic data that you generated gretto
synthetics is also business source
licensed um I don't find um I think it's
a good tool um you should check it out I
I don't think all of the tutorials are
super up to date but I think you can
still follow along quite well um since
then synthetic
data uh that one is by white data that
one is quite nice as well and then they
also have a profile into that's why you
see the two boxes that are quite
similar and then so why does this matter
why does synthetic data matter well you
can increase privacy um you can do cost
efficient analysis so if you think about
uh experiments so um the other day I was
doing this talk as a workshop at odsc
West uh this past Monday and one of the
uh attendees in my talk she works at a
pharmaceutical company um at a drug
development company and one of the
things that they're trying to do with
synthetic data is to generate data for
patients and try to see if they they can
generate similar enough data so that the
FDA could come close to approving a drug
that wasn't uh particularly developed on
real people uh per se but it was you it
was developed using real or synthetic
data and that's quite interesting
because if you think about it there's a
lot of um um there's a lot of
experiments that are happening right now
or that continue to happen where you
need human samples human you need humans
to be able to test those experiments is
it possible that we could create um
synthetic data to get the results of
generating new drugs that will help cure
some diseases without having to put
people through some uh hardships CU some
all those some of those experiments can
go uh quite um quite badly I remember
when I was at unit uh I got a call from
uh pharmaceutical U or from a lab in
Miss St and they say hey would you love
to um would you love to do an experiment
with us and come in and stay at our lab
for a few days uh we're going to pay you
about $5,000 $5,000 and you know as a
broke student you're like $5,000 go on
um what are you talking about and then
they said well look we have to this as a
disclaimer we have to tell you what
could go wrong and I said go on um it's
$5,000 and they said well there's a 10%
chance that you could go blind cuz we're
going to put something in your eyes but
but don't worry 90% it will be fine and
I said well thank you very much uh but
no thank you uh this was about 11 years
ago now and um I still remember remember
like there has to be people that goes
through that for uh this drugs to be
developed and I can only feel for those
who have landed on the 10% that has gone
wrong uh data augmentation uh one of the
coolest examples uh with synthetic data
is uh in particular in the um Auto in
the Auto industry where you think of
autonomous driving Vehicles you are not
always going to have all of the edge
cases that your cameras or your Radars
could detect but if you have synthetic
data being generated with um that in
mind the the fact that you want to
create cases that your car that your
cameras have never captured but you know
could happen wouldn't that save you a
lot of money and also a lot of time it
could make your car safer uh of maintain
the data with things that could be real
that could happen in the road
uh then better Ed Case detection which
that ties up with what I just mentioned
uh increase customization you could also
create things that just haven't happened
similar in the same ve things that
haven't happened but could happen uh
faster Pro faster approval Concept in
the same way of uh the same thing that I
mentioned about uh experimentation for
drug companies and then less labeling um
as
well okay so machine learning generated
data um so what is it deep learning Moto
architectures that learn to produce
Noble data after being shown countless
of example you're like I see okay go on
uh what are you talking about so how do
we get started so there's about there's
about four architectures that are widely
used today uh one is generative
adversarial networks the other one is
variational a to ENC outto enclosers um
diffusion models and flow based models
let's describe all of those and let's
and then let's give you an example so
that you can have an idea of what they
are so generated aaral networks um these
are a class of machine learning
algorithms that consist of two networks
one is called uh the generator and the
other one is the um the discriminator
you pitch these two against each other
and one is trying to fool you into hey
this is this is fake this is not fake
and the other one is kind of like a
detective it's trying to detect it's
trying to call your out um
essentially and so that's really what it
is and then um and actually I removed
that image from the previous one but
we're going to see it here in a second
um okay so the other one is variational
outo encoders um this are architecture
that have two things uh an encoder um
architecture and a decoder architecture
and they're kind of similar to what um
CH gbt is uh the GPT models are doing
like gpt3 GPT 4 and so on um the main
difference is that I believe gpt3 and uh
3.5 they are decoder only architectures
and then other models like T5 um that's
the actual name of it uh is has both a
decoder and an encoder models like BT
they have an En uh an encoder only and
the difference between those two is the
decoder is better at generating or one
of the differences is that the decoder
is better at generating he can do a lot
of stuff that the encoder can and then
the encoder is better uh grabbing some
context uh grabbing the sample and then
doing a task on so for example birth
might be um faster and easier to use for
sentiment classification and other
particular kind of TXS that are not
necessarily text
generation okay so then variational outo
and cordus uh what are this ones so
these are probabilistic generative
models in machine learning that enable
efficient learning uh and generation of
complex data by encoding input data into
a lower dimensional space and decoding
it back to generate diverse
samples okay so you the 3.5 clot Lama 2
are class or are similar to vas they're
not exactly V Transformers and vas um
are different but they have a similar
architecture where they have the encoder
and the
decoder um then we have diffusion models
diffusion models are like on rubbling I
put a little analogy here there're like
unraveling a suspenseful story at first
you see everything clearly but then the
plot THS um and then aail mystery no uh
noise descends and then with a chapter
and with each chapter there's a time
stamp you keep in one part of the motor
you're adding noise say to an image and
then another part of the motel is trying
to den noise it so you add say black
dots or pixels into an image and then
you try to decipher what was the picture
that will make of this one in the best
way
possible um so stable diffusion is the
one of the most prominent examples of
this one but there are also other
incredible ones like audio ldm and I
have an example of that one and refusion
uh and then the last one is flow based
models these are also very cool models
um but I feel like they're not they
don't have as much uh they don't have as
much attention as um Transformers and uh
diffusion models so flow based models
they're generative models in machine
learning that learn a bjective mapping
between a simple distribution gaou and
the tar Target distribution allowing for
efficient generation of high quality
samples by trans transforming random
noise through the learn mapping uh and
then some examples is real MVP and I
have an example here so that if you have
never heard of that model um you can see
it here in a second so one example is um
this picture this per this person
actually doesn't exist and this was
generated by a um by an adversarial
Network by a gun and then if I go up and
then I come down you're going to see
another one and then if I go open down
you're also going to see another person
there um none of these people exist but
it's prettyy impressive to think that if
we didn't know better we would say like
oh yeah I just saw this person this
morning um then diffusion example so um
this is one of my favorite models uh
that I've seen is called um audio ldm
let me see if I can actually play this
one here I might not be able
to let's see if I
can
so this is when it was first
created and this is I believe at the
beginning of the at the beginning of the
video you see um the very first model
out of your ldm one and now you see um
you see the second version of
[Music]
it and then you can see the prompt at
the
bottom so very very impressive models
and um the reason why Um this can work
quite well is because of the
representation in which audio gets
converted into so when you have a a
string of audio then you have some sort
of signal that signal gets converted
into a digital format that we call Audio
so sound goes and becomes audio and then
that digital format be can become H an
image that we call a spectrogram once
you have an image you can treat audio in
a similar way as you do actual images
that's why we can do some of these cool
things with them um a flow-based model
uh a really cool example that I found it
was graph AF I don't know what the AF
stands for I thought it were you know it
could have been a quite nerdy way of
describing graphs but I'm just making
fun of it but it's a it's a really cool
paper that talks about how to create
molecular graph uh generation with flow
based
models and then uh for the last uh piece
so why do they matter uh why are these
things important well uh realism so
machine learning generated data
especially through advanced Motors like
Gans they can closely mimic real data
and capture like very very detail
patterns in pictures in order of that
they can make things
that yes they don't exist but you like
who maybe this should
exist uh the other one that's various
applications suitable for a wide range
of applications including image
generation text style transfer style
transfer I think is quite cool um if you
think about retail um and imagine that a
person
says Hey I want to see myself inside
this picture here's a picture of me in
my whole body and then you could put a
t-shirt or a piece of clothing um in a
person and then they tell you well I
like it but can it be red can it be blue
and so like kind of transforming the
experiences in which with which we
purchase or which uh experiences that of
how we do
things uh and then another one is
learning enhancement so um data
generated by Machine learning can
enhance the performance of other models
by providing additional training
examples but there's a caveat there and
I should have put like a like an
asterisk at the end because um they can
also make it
works okay things to watch out for uh
especially in fake data uh fake data May
lack the complexity and the nuances of
the real world when you take a randomly
generated data it's going to come from a
distribution and it's gonna and
everything is going to look kind of the
same space out the same and so on um so
it can be very unsuitable for in
particular training machine learning
models so there's limited applicability
there because for what I said now um You
couldn't train a machine learning model
with fake data you could but it's
probably not going to come out very well
uh synthetic data um there's complexity
generating high quality data the better
quality the more quality you want in a
data set the more you have to think
through how you going to sample from the
distribution that generated that data to
create a one one that mimics the actual
one um uh validation difficulty ensuring
the synthetic data uh accurately
represents the original data is crucial
um and that's something that makes you
stop think before before you can deploy
or before you can use it in some sort of
way and then thanks to which I for uh
the last one resource intensive training
this uh machine learning generated
models uh generated this models that
generate synthetic data it can be very
very um costly and then lastly there can
also be ethical concerns um as you can
see those people they look like they
could be real um so say for example you
paste one of those images in an ID and
now you kind of like go by and try to
create a fake persona uh in some way so
that could be quite problematic uh
here's also Al deep fakes like don't
forget about that that's probably the
worst one like um there's a lot of
examples online of deep fakes and how
people are impersonating other people in
particular um a targeted Community or a
targeted Persona demographic is women uh
uh with there's been porn scandles uh
people using de fakes for uh to address
people and and that's something that
brings very uh the ethical concerns uh
of this technology to the Forefront and
they should be taken
seriously uh okay so so scenarios uh I
mentioned earlier Healthcare you I think
one of the biggest applications of
synthetic data is in the healthcare
space right now like I wouldn't want my
information to be leaked and then be
used in some sort Moto without my
consent I would like it to be used if
it's going to help for something but
maybe I wouldn't like it without my
consent and in U there are ways in which
this is being done one in particular is
called Federated learning I believe
there was a talk yesterday about it I
wasn't able to see it and I don't know
if they were talking about Healthcare
but I know Federated learning um is
being used use for use cases where you
cannot access the data because it it has
personally identifiable information but
Healthcare that's probably the main one
or one of the biggest ones uh in the
automotive industry I should have put a
nice looking one there but I just
thought that was a nice picture um so in
the automotive
industry a lot of deaths all across the
world not just the US are through
driving I believe my home country the
Dominican Republic was named in the last
10 years one of the worst countries to
drive at which I kind of think about it
in a positive way you learn how to drive
over there and like you're good to go
you can go anywhere and you'll be safe
so um that's one of the way that I like
to think about it but if we could
improve it uh with some sort of
synthetic data with some better training
cameras are going to become more uous in
inside cards not necessarily to make it
autonomous but to make it a little bit
safer to drive so is there any way in
which we can use synthetic data to train
models that could advice us or maybe not
advice us but alert us in specific
moments something might
happen uh in banking as well synthetic
data to create uh new experiences for
banking so the things that you can do in
a highly regulated industry they're
quite limited what if you could create U
data to create new experiences without
having to go and tell the users hey I
use your data to see if this experience
will work and then or to train this
particular model um it didn't but don't
worry we're going to get rid of the DAT
we're going to get rid of the model and
all the things that we did with your
data and so there's a
separation of concerns there uh retail I
mentioned the example where what if I
just put my body my figure and I said I
want a t-shirt of this kind I want a I
want some pants of this color and then
it could just put it on me in an image
and I'll be like okay that would be nice
um two of those so that would be a cool
a cool application that could come up um
and it will be with synthetic
data and then okay so now uh I have a
little demo uh for everyone
I mentioned I was going to use my uh my
mises um and a couple of the tools and
let me see if we can see this better
okay so here we
have here we have my M this one is a
fake data generate uh generator tool um
one of the coolest things is it has
different classes for what you need so
there's a main class called generic that
you can use to generate different
personas different addresses different
demographic information but also uh
geographic information of sorts and uh
but you can also split it into different
into different things so for example
here I have the Persona the data the
text and the generic then you have the
local the local is the thing that allows
you to describe where you want your
distribution your fake distribution to
come from um and also information
particular information about it so for
example here we have the Persona class
and you can see um let me scroll down um
you have identifiers tell so all
demographic information that you been
interested in
uh phone number um language uh academic
degree that you would want for a person
University that that person might uh
might have gone to nationality uh
worldview and so on and then um if you
want to access uh particular things you
can also split it in different ways so I
have the gender class and I can say I
want a female I want a male I don't know
if it has a different kind of uh if it
accounts for different for other genders
I do know that it's very uh
straightforward to create create a new
class and inject it into the application
which makes it really really cool cuz
things that are not in this fake data
generator you could add them it from the
synthetic synthetic data world as well
um so here we have Jo Johna uh Fox um
and then you can also have a mail uh
stepen Cortez here we have a different
example where you can say I want a
person from Ukraine and actually that's
a little bit confusing it's not UK uh
the UK Great Britain is UK Ukraine so
here you have uh the time the local time
over there or the date time a random
date uh over there if you were to access
the time it would give you the time in
that part of the world um uh then you
can get a quote uh from different places
and so on you can generate usernames you
can generate um dat times you can
generate uh different names from
different variations um you can also do
it from Spanish Agosto uh paa fruit um
and then you can also have one last
thing that I find really compelling and
is if you get this thing called field
set you can assign how many how many
samples do I want I want a 100 but I can
put a thousand I can put 10,000 20,000
and so on and then I can start creating
things different things um to be able to
um so say for example I have my little
um I have my variable called fs and I
put here
username
oops okay there you go so now I
generated about 100 usernames for me but
if I say um
random.
randint I think I have to give it um let
me see if actually works if it has some
defaults it doesn't have some defaults
but you can also use a specific classes
from it to generate um let's see a = 1
bals 100 ah there you go um so you can
generate U different um different
variations of numbers that are randomly
generated one more minute okay cool and
then we have on the other use case we
have the actual synthetic data um and I
have different demos here but say for
example um you have a fake Hotel guests
and then you have your data frame here
you're going to have credit card numbers
which you definitely don't want that to
be leaked that will be considered
personally identifiable information uh
billing address and and the email of a
person um you're going to get a piece of
information for that data set that
you're going to call um the metadata
then you're going to get um you're going
to assign you're going to create pick a
method that you want to use to generate
synthetic data from that data set here
they have a class called Fast ML and
that applies the um the Baseline model
to generate synthetic data from and then
so I pass in my real data and then I
give it a number of samples this is not
the same as in pandas where you say
sample give me random samples from a
data set this is saying I want to
generate a specific amount of samples so
now I have from this one I have
different um I have a synthetic data but
notice what it does for you it Maps the
personal identifiable information to
specific variables that he understands
has this kind of information and then it
mask it so here we have example.org but
if we come right up here we have brown.
bis uh neil.com and so on um and then
also for the credit card it also Maps it
to a different one so it doesn't
generate actual credit card numbers from
it um you can also um check by
specifically ring some of them and then
checking that it didn't um generate
anything that could have been in the
real data set and then you can generate
uh little reports that tell you that
compare the quality of the synthetic
data generated versus the quality of the
real so how similar is my synthetically
uh generated data to the real one and
that's something that you really care
about because the closer it is to
reality uh the better you can also
compare um different uh the real one in
in different ways you can compare the
real one with the uh uh with the fake
one and then lastly uh well actually um
I did I did okay I I did have an example
on uh machine learning generated data
but I think everybody here is quite um
uh probably uh used to interacting with
some of these tools um and the one
example that I have here is like you can
put a phrase in a particular language
and you can use a um a machine learning
model to generate uh to translate it or
to generate different texes based on
your input and uh with that um let me
put the one last time I want to say
thank you everyone for coming the key
takeaway that I have is that you can do
a lot with synthetic data but don't do
it
all uh well thank you very much
everyone